a lot of people say that we live in such
a mediated age you know so many signals
so many platforms are competing for our
attention that effectively now we live
in an attention economy we live in the
age of attention the currency today is
the currency of your attention right we
want to cannibalize that evanescent flux
of sensation and perception that is all
we have and all we are and so you ask
yourself is this a good thing to be
mindlessly occupied and entertained
every day till death do us part with it
not necessarily any good content you
know but just something that fills in
the void but there is an antidote my
friends there is an alternative currency
a utopian currency and I call it the
currency of inspiration the currency of
wonderment the currency of curiosity
wouldn't it be nice if instead of being
concerned about our careers we were
concerned about our curiosities we were
satiated and maintained by our passion
as it burns away all obstacles before us
I mean come on and so in the space of
content in the space of information
exchange perhaps we should stop worrying
about colonizing individuals limited
attention spans and creating digit free
Nia and manic depression but instead
create media that matters that enriches
that expands the human imagination that
shares goosebumps technologically
mediated through the ether sphere so
that all of us feel closer to one
another feel like we are part of a
larger symbiotic
Gizem and that William is in this field
was love and wonder and awe and cosmic
curiosity and wouldn't this be the best
age instead of the age of attention aged
off age one dirty page of bliss the age
of something better
you